a city of 100,000 residents has been
poisoned by water contaminated with
toxic lead and I'm not talking about a
developing country here I'm talking
about Flint Michigan here in the US so
how did a poisonous element like lead
get into Flint's water and is what's
happening in Flint a sign of things to
come across the country the city's water
problem started in April 2014 when to
save money the state of Michigan
switched Flint's water source from Lake
Huron to the Flint River almost
immediately
Flint's residents started complaining
that the funky tasting brown water
coming out of their taps was causing
rashes and other health problems that's
because the Flint River is 19 times more
corrosive than Lake Huron and the
saltier water started to eat away at the
lead pipes just a few months after the
switch lead poisoning doubled in
children 5 years old and younger lead
poisoning is linked to lower IQs and
often irreversible behavioral health and
developmental problems and to add insult
to injury Flint residents water bills
were some of the highest in the country
at 150 dollars a month which can be
burdensome in a city with 16%
unemployment and 44% poverty in November
2015 citizens of Flint filed a
class-action lawsuit against governor
rick Snyder the state of Michigan the
city of Flint and other officials the
lawsuit alleges that cost cuts were put
ahead of the health of citizens and it
lists several health effects believed to
be a result of the contaminated water
these include hair loss skin lesions
vision loss and depression Michigan's
Department of Environmental Quality
should have prevented the lead poisoning
by treating the water with anti
corrosives but reportedly chose not to
because it would have cost $100 a day
and now replacing the collapsed
infrastructure is estimated to cost up
to 1.5 billion dollars and while it's
Flint that's currently suffering what's
happening there could happen in other
communities across the country according
to a 2012 report by the American Water
Works Association the water
infrastructure in the country is under
threat of total collapse possibly
costing one trillion dollars in repairs
the next few decades meaning we could
see more instances of water
contamination as a result of old pipes
as well as higher water bills for
Americans living in effective
communities in 2013 the American Society
for civil engineers graded the United
States drinking water infrastructure
addy pointing to 240,000 water main
breaks per year a lot of the US water
infrastructure is at least 100 years old
and it hasn't helped that federal
funding for water and waste systems was
cut about 80 percent over the last four
decades that means consumers face a
bigger bill for water and waste system
upkeep and that doesn't come cheap but
some states like Illinois Pennsylvania
and Massachusetts are responding to the
breakdown in water infrastructure in
some of their communities with the money
needed to repair and rebuild so with
such a basic necessity under threat how
many more Flint's will it take for the
federal government to make a real
commitment to the country's water
you